yeah it went welcome to this video
playing blecch x7 from Poland right so
we get him the Roxy bind and I have an
idea that oops that was close to a primo
failure you don't really expect people
to take them strengthens my centers are
a bit surprising ok so how do i play
this dilution the night coming to see
fire looks like a decent idea so let's
do that yeah 95 I mean I don't know he
might I cannot take it rook t1 bill is
on I wonder this is an idea trying to
take ok much let's do it ok so he
doesn't mind my capture them
so who do I play him hmm we should be
six and something nyame should be 68
it's interesting he might have f4 this
is a move that irritates me a little bit
Andrew before appearance also looking
like some annoyance where are you there
this is sorry good when it's at five in
this position is that when i answered no
why would why would that draw as five is
interesting maybe you think I'm
disconnected because I actually think
about moves and how an interesting
choice takes Bishop takes wins the
exchange so that natural move doesn't
work and i have potentially taking and
f4 it's not an easy decision though
because it looks extremely weakening
this mode and if I'd something that I
can take and it isn't this nice that
would be loose and so now I can take a
couple of times and when they exchange
right i also have f4 which would be
strategically also quite nice f4 to f3
hmm it's very tempting actually then
kinky and Bishop takes Knight takes
Queen takes the [ __ ] at five yeah I'm an
exchanger but is there a good position I
don't know
this is very tempting I get all the way
I get to f3 that's a quite annoying fan
and now f3 or I can also just play for
for a good position there with the file
so yeah now like this should be six and
please playing against the Y can take
and Queen h5 immediately switch into the
Kings side it's also attractive
okay I'm not getting them quickly
tweenage three Queen f1 will the good
faith wide how can i do that would be
fantastic to get in like bishop age 32
g2 wants to play c5 you know I'm going
to stop that come on Oh green fire but I
who I'm lucky he cannot win the exchange
order the key cannot window look I have
a queen age three at the end that sets
extremely lucky extremely lucky by now
Bishop f5 is good isn't it I mean why
not yes to go to f1 basically white
knowledge ok yeah loopy one is coming it
doesn't really have much activity there
and then I we played the initial moves
extremely quickly i I don't know I mean
around here it's not not clear to me at
all how this is to be evaluated he
played a swim the engine suggested
player guess you want simply avoiding
the double porn scenario when I think
this is okay yeah this structure really
sucks and it doesn't look like the main
question is always is there something
that you can do against the king and it
doesn't feel very dangerous at the
moment yeah now that that went into f5
now after that I can take the material
or play a fallen which was tough to
decide I feel I mean this was the
alternative I wasn't sure here Queen a3
the engine is just thinking and winning
or more or less winning would you know
for human player this Bishop feels
dangerous my king is open I know this
wasn't bad I think from a practical
point of view because I mean what what
does he play now he played this after
which f3 or e5 both are good and this is
definitely great for me I mean the Queen
erstanding excellently here covers this
and I have the better structure I'm
actually really surprised at the engine
is killing 0.2 we're why isn't this
complete completely terrible void I've
got to be five okay it looks pretty
terrible now this is just is just not
not fun to play maybe I should have
considered when I taking is maybe
debatable but this cannot be bad IAM
cannot be a bad position I completely
blended there with this I mean I did not
see Queen d 50 actually and this is a
queen trade I didn't see that either I
have to trade creaks and I mean that
position is not terrible of course
completely unnecessary Bush basics was
good yeah and this is instead losing
quickly oh yeah Queen D Phi D has to
play now some of that that check and
quickly escape my my attention down I
was just thinking okay come on I'm
blocking I'm blocking the bishop pair
and preventing c5 but I can also do it
like that this is just better now here
there are also ideas like this and this
and just win the pawn in some cases
right so it's very nice thank you
completely wonder that that Queen d5
check okay yes thanks for watching